il a été accueilli en héros lors du
dévoilement de la programmation de jazz
folk mais qui est vraiment né à toronto
a women's elle est un élève turbulent et
après l'école secondaire il devient
vendeur de tapis à 23 ans et présente
ses premières blagues sur la scène du
cabaret vioxx à toronto 1979 il vole la
vedette dans un communiq lob de los
angeles
il est très vite embauchés sur les
plateaux de télévision ces numéros comme
celui du bébé font fureur
[Musique]
évidemment même de prêter sa voix au
personnage de gizmo pour le film
gremlins véritable bête de scène
ah oui mandole obtiendra la
reconnaissance à l'international avec
l'émission dit le new deal dont
l'audimat dépassent les 10 millions de
téléspectateurs
puis il devient juge à la tout aussi
populaire émission america's got talent
dans la foulée de tout ce succès à
wimbledon devient copropriétaire de just
for life qui n'en a parlé dans un livre
si jamais vous croisez à women d'or dans
les rues de montréal
ne lui demandez surtout pas de vous
serrer la pince et fuel à 82 62 ans est
loin de penser à la retraite après son
passage à montréal cet été
il animera à nouveau deal or no deal et
ce n'est qu'un de ses nombreux projets
ici louis philippe ouimet razouk inde à
montréal